via la parole est à monsieur philippe
meunier merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur modulaire
et que nos bleus allaient eux 2 500
salariés de renault trucks s'il vous
plaît et anciennement berliet
entreprises de rhône alpes qui renvoie
une grande tradition industrielle
française sont une nouvelle fois frappé
par un plan de licenciement
la volonté les fonds d'investissement
actionnaire de volvo de dévitaliser nos
sites de production doit mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs publics état et
collectivités locales en 2008 suite à la
crise des subprimes on notera que c'est
la filière automobile française ont été
sauvée du dépôt de bilan grâce à un prêt
de 6,5 milliards d'euros décidé et mis
en oeuvre par nicolas sarkozy et
françois fillon prêt remboursé avec
intérêts aujourd'hui il s'agit de
prendre des mesures aussi forte et
efficace
nous ne pouvons donc nous satisfaire
seulement d'un accompagnement du plan
social comme le propose le gouvernement
après en avoir discuté avec les
syndicats au côté de xavier breton dit
blanc puis de laurent wauquiez hier
matin au cours d'une réunion très
constructive et convient maintenant de
prendre toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour mettre en oeuvre les
investissements afin de renouveler la
gamme des camions médium duty pour
pérenniser le magasin central d'europe
afrique sur le site de vénissieux saint
priest pour développer ensuite la gamme
de production sur le site de bourg en
bresse
ces mesures sont d'autant plus attendues
que le carnet de commandes le permet à
l'instar des pays comme l'allemagne de
l'angleterre
tu dois être mis en oeuvre pour
maintenir en france et en rhône alpes
cette filière stratégique pour notre
industrie et notre défense
monsieur le ministre par respect à
l'égard des salariés de renault trucks
et des français ne répondait pas à ses
ici un transport par autocar ou
extension du travail du dimanche
nos compatriotes salariés de renault
trucks exige des mesures complètes et
efficace de leurs gouvernements jour
merci merci la parole est un monsieur
emmanuel macron ministre de l'économie
de l'industrie et du numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
vous rassure j'ai toujours au moins le
même respect que vous pour les salariés
qui sont en difficulté et les situations
de ce type
la preuve en est c'est que ce matin
accompagné de gérard collomb
et nous avons pu ensuite discuté avec
yves blein que vous évoquiez j'ai reçu
les dirigeants de volvo et les
dirigeants de renault trucks précisément
pour qu'ils s'expliquent de cette
annonce
vous avez mentionné à juste titre les
garanties que l'état français a apporté
à cette entreprise sans malheureusement
avoir de contrepartie politique ni
sécurisé et celle ci à l'époque et je le
regrette comme vous je le regrette comme
vous et vous savez la difficulté de ces
situations en avril dernier lorsque
l'entreprise volvo pour la première fois
après des décennies d'une coopération
longue fructueuse avec l'état français a
annoncé précisément cette décision de
restructurer le premier ministre
lui-même puis françois rebsamen et moi
même avons immédiatement réagi pour
qualifié cette décision d' inacceptable
à aucun moment nous n'avons considéré
que le rôle de l'état devait se borner à
accompagner une forme de fatalité et
donc sur ce sujet je rejoins votre
indignation comme je rejoins sel et des
salariés qui se sont encore exprimés ce
matin il n'est en effet pas acceptable
qu'une telle décision nous ait été
notifié
de la sorte après 500 suppressions
d'emplois qui ont été décidées en 2014
ce qui a été demandé aux décideurs de
volvo et de renault trucks ce matin
c'est d'une part de revoir les annonces
qui ont été faites pour ne pas procéder
à des listes des licenciements secs
c'est ensuite de prendre des engagements
clairs avec les nouveaux dirigeants et
l'état français ainsi que les
collectivités pour s'engager à ce que
les centres de recherche et
développement les centres de production
qui sont en particulier dans la région
lyonnaise puissent faire l'objet de
réinvestissement et d'engagements fermes
et c'est qu'ensuite les clarifications
soient apportés pour l'emploi
précisément des salariés avec les
territoires et le gouvernement pour que
les annonces faites en avril puisse être
revu donc nous sommes aux côtés des
salariés et la copie qui a été présentée
sera améliorée merci monsieur le
ministre